MOVE.E-THROW FROMIS PLAY.ICATOC
OF HOW THEY PLAYING WELSH
SHOOTING THE THREE
SQUEEZES IT, SETS UP THEHE LIT
UP IN A HURRY.
>> Michael: MIKE WHAT I HAVE
TIME COMES FROM, WHEW, THE
STRENGTH OF THE
SECOND.
IRVING, CROSS OVER, INSIDE,
LEFT HAND AMBIDEXTROUS,
LOOK AT THIS
SEASON. DRUMMOND.
IRVING
STRIPE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
NUMBERS, IT'S THE BROOKLYN.
BUT IT ISN'T JUST CAREER.
NETS LED BY AS MANY AS 30.
AM PRETTY SURE
BROWN.
AND A LITTLE BIT OF TROUBLE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS HOT
STOV50-POINT GAMES IN A SEASON
JOINING ELGIN BAYLOR A
ILLUSIVENESS, BRAZDEIKIS TRIGF
ALL THE TALENTS THAT WE HAVE
CONTINUE T
JAKOB5% SINCE THE BREAK. THE TEO
THE F
SAN ANTONIO.
AND THE WOLVES CATCH  JUMPERS, E
FLOOR.
>> Dave: EDWARDS,
>> Jim:
DEFENSE HAS NOT BEEN THE STRONG
SU
TOWNS
FLOOR. TIMBERWOLVES GET A STOP.
12 MINUTES.
TOWNS MOV
PLAYER OVER.
LONNIE WALKER HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD.
HE HAS SET
TOWNS STEPS
MAKE IT 32 IN THE QUARTER AND HE
HAS TIED
TOWNS ROOTED AGAIN, TH